he's the guy that put the timberwolves  on the map  the 12 seasons he was here he was the  franchise  when kg came along people took us  serious  he always brought it every night  his intensity and his trash talking was  superb you take this outfit home  and you burn it you sit in the first  couple of rows of targets then you're  here we're gonna go ahead and miss the  choke city you want an mvp for us took  the wolves to the western conference  finals  and that was the best time to be a wolf  fan kevin garnett is the greatest  power forward of all time you're the big  ticket for a reason  i'm so happy you got that ring in boston  can't wait for 21 to be retired you are  the franchise you are minneapolis you  are minnesota  congratulations on making it to hall of  fame thanks big ticket